when the most powerful backroom man in
Westminster is in a hurry people want to
know why
here Dominic Cummings scurrying out of
Downing Street four days after Boris
Johnson told the nation to stay at home
to save lives where he went next and why
could have big implications for the
government this evening I must give the
British people a very simple instruction
you must stay at home you should not be
meeting friends if your friends ask you
to meet you should say no you should not
be meeting family members who do not
live in your home mr. Cummings were seen
rushing from Downing Street on March the
27th after it was announced that Boris
Johnson and Matt Hancock had tested
positive for coronavirus Downing Street
said he'd developed symptoms over the
weekend of the 28th and 29th of March on
Tuesday March the 31st durham police
received a report that an individual had
traveled from London to Durham and
officers made contact with him The
Guardian is also reporting the witness
saw mr. Cummings at the grounds of his
parents home near Durham with a young
child on April the 5th less than seven
days after displaying symptoms he was
photographed in Downing Street just over
a week later Durham Police said later
they had contacted his family to remind
them of the rules on self isolation and
unnecessary travel stopping short of
quite saying the PM's chief adviser had
broken them but labour want answers the
British people do not expect there to be
one rule for them and another rule for
Dominic Cummings number 10 need to
provide a very swift explanation for his
actions it's hard to overstate just how
central Dominic Cummings is to Boris
Johnson's government and has been from
the moment both men walked in to number
10 last summer whether you're an ally or
a foe or even just a Whitehall bystander
all say that Cummings is absolutely
central to operations where he directs
he interferes even on occasion
intimidates so don't expect decisions to
be taken lightly even though the
involvement of the police means this is
a serious charge
opposition suggesting a resignation may
be in order if it's true that Dominic
Cummings has breached these guidelines
he should resign if he doesn't resign he
can be sent at a time when millions of
people are really making significant
sacrifices in order to stick to the
rules
it seems that Dominic Cummings has gone
halfway across England um when he was
symptomatic so I think an awful lot of
people will be incredibly shocked that
he did this and Boris Johnson needs to
sack him Downing Street has not
officially responded to the story but
they seem set to argue Dominic Cummings
and his wife were so ill they needed
their child to be cared for by
grandparents number 10 appeared to want
to tough it out Sam code Sky News